of new developments in the investigation
of the murders of four University of
Idaho students they were Remembered at a
very emotional memorial service on
Friday and their roommates paid their
respects in a written message as Lilia
Luciano reports there have still been no
arrest it's been three weeks since the
four students were found stabbed to
death in their beds
Maddie Kaylee Zanna and Ethan were truly
all one of a kind
family and friends came together Friday
honoring the lives of the four Idaho
college students brutally murdered last
month a local Pastor read a letter from
two roommates Who police say were home
and survived the killings and broke
their silence for the first time Dylan
Mortensen wrote this about losing her
close friends tizana and Ethan the two
best friends but perfect pair together
they had this Unstoppable loving
relationship and from Bethany funk you
all were gifts to this world in your own
special way
and it just won't be the same without
you
police say roommates Madison Mogan
Kaylee Gonzalez xanaker Noodle and
kernodle's boyfriend Ethan Chapin were
all stabbed on November 13th likely
between three and six in the morning
while police have no suspect weapon or
motive they are still saying this was a
targeted attack it didn't appear that
there was any force entry into the home
you know there were two survivors and as
well the actual crime scenes themselves
really lead detectives and the chief to
firmly and continue to believe that this
was targeted the lack of an arrest is
fueling frustration among some of the
victims families not in the immediate
circle by any means but a few of the
names that have been circulating around
I think it's hard not to kind of you
know dig into this and I don't know how
much of that is just because we have so
little information from law enforcement
for CBS mornings Lilia Luciano